and then mary you still standing by hi
hi thank you so much
no it was interesting i i love hearing
about the moms
in the rap audience
right finally something we could relate
to i feel like a mom at any rap show
yeah right i always feel like a mom
nowadays i have i'm not mom are we
started are we interviewing
yeah obviously my next guest you know
are from ponies
you've got some great sets on there also
from solar opposite on hulu
mary mack thank you for being here hi
moses thanks for having me
it's nice to be here i'm in uh
minneapolis
this summer i was mostly staying in a
camper up in
northern wisconsin in the in the real
woods and um
i did not uh i showered in a lake and
that was
that was um every day i write running
water
in my gratitude journal that's great
because yeah it's not so much showering
in a lake as just soaking in filthier
water
what not joking
we lived in a camper for the first uh 10
years of my
yeah wow we could probably swap tips
[Music]
we could swap tips where do you empty
the septic tank are you going with the
blue one
do you want a compostable system because
those things never work
i know i've gone through all that you
know what i do
i keep i had to i had to google the
instructions i
i don't know if i should look at the
camera at you but i need to google these
we want you to look at the corner of
your room if you look at the back corner
of your
your room line should be yeah if you
could completely turn yourself it's just
more engaging
google the instructions on this european
sani party
that came with my camper it was very
complicated
and i cut a lot of people um
talk about the walk of shame um yeah my
walk of shame
is when i like walk into a wayside rest
to empty my camper um my portable camper
toilet
because everyone knows what that is they
make them blue
so everyone's like oh there's all your
feces that's your box of feces
[Laughter]
and there's no beige yours is blue
your your your sani potty was blue
i saw a guy get in a fight with someone
at a campground while he was holding his
septic tank he just emptied it
and it's like well you you lose whatever
you're saying oh yeah i hope
you put some respect on my name oh it's
like you
you have a box yeah yeah you're you just
you could it's a lot it's a real
exclamation point on whatever you're
saying is when you release your
own human excrement out of a receptacle
okay yes in case you didn't know what to
talk about i
i brought a list of possible topics
self learning moses i'm not for it
uh i i'm the kind of person who's like
just put your head down and shut up and
do your work
but you know you know what the pandemic
has done for people
too much self-realization okay
i learned about myself that the greatest
sense of accomplishment
i can ever feel is when i'm almost done
with a bar of soap wow
yeah yeah you can see what you've
accomplished you're like oh all that
showering is paying off
and and it's like why do i get so
excited it's not like you can cross it
off the list moses you can't be like
done showering um but i get so excited
because i never
i've been on the road for 18 years like
i never
get to finish a bar of soap but thanks
to donald trump
and this great pandemic of ours uh i
look at how good i'm doing look how thin
these are oh you brought it oh i brought
it
you never see them that thin in 18 years
i've never finished a bar of soap
and i because i'm always gone and look
at how good i'm doing like
look at how look at all this and no hair
on him look at this
no hair thank god this i think i think
you need to rebrand and you need to sell
thin soap for people that need
accomplishments in their life
yeah like the training wheel of soap
absolutely you get that thin you get
that accomplishment you're
welcome america if we're lucky we'll
have
at least six more months of pandemic so
i can finish these soaps
yeah okay moses do you have a superpower
no i have no super power well i do
what is it is your boss conan o'brien
yeah since you're working for team coco
yeah
okay so guess what when i wake up in the
morning i don't even have to do anything
in my hair i took i got it on my phone
my hair
is as good as conan o'brien's as soon as
i get up
you see that air that's my hair in the
morning
it looks look at that height that
perfect
swoop what's the secret for waking up
with good hair
sleep hard sleep hard have stress dreams
sleep hard
nightmares the sweat and anxiety will
exfoliate
follicle oh sure sweat anxiety
dog hair you want it all in there and
then it help
it gives it a little extra lift before
you move on the last
business idea you didn't ask for this
but the superpower for the hair
you have a salon that's just nothing but
twin beds
people lay in the salon and then they
wake up with great hair
that is a good idea you know what though
what if you did a little helper and you
were like
i'll do their hair while they're
sleeping well isn't that a time
saver and a multi-billion dollar idea
i think only you could get away with
that business i think that
um the smaller you are and the quieter
you are at night since they're sleeping
um the better you the more success
you'll have
and if you know a little bit about hair
or if you have a battery operated
curling iron
very big big help you don't know where
their outlets are
moses you don't know if they got an
outlet behind the bed
what if they only have a usb charger and
you weren't prepared for that with your
curling iron
right to-do list for conan
if you could let them know and if you
could let
ruthie and jp who elsa work there no
the last time i was on conan they blew
up my cd album
my last cd i have a different cd album
out out
but this one they blew it up and then
what happened was
conan and andy signed it very nicely
but then i started in some plastic in a
in a closet in los
angeles when i was out there and this is
the kind of air quality in la
you guys it just ate it's just the acid
of either the plastic or the air just
chewed it away
like this is not supposed to be there
and and they did a nice job
took a lot of time to sign it and now
it's just looks like hell and i
i really would like it if if they could
find it in their busy schedules
if i could send them this and they could
recreate it
maybe would try to be as authentic as
they were the first time
because i would like to put on my wall
but you want the same message on there
the same heartfelt message
but a redo
i will pay the postage hey
i apologize if my conversation is a
little too mundane
i'm enjoying this it's the small things
in life
that you gotta think about moses like in
this time of impending doom
and um wretchedness and
it just uh putridity you have to just
focus on what you can control the small
things
right like like who the [ __ ] is using
metal spatulas
on my teflon pants
who's who's doing it is it dogs
my husband's the only one that lives
here get that
mistake this was a huge mistake you
better
you better not be using that on a
nonstick pan
i i cook everything on a paper plate
over the stove i have a very bad life
and i have a can of beans like dennis
the menace
i hope so but this is the worst purchase
i made
in quarantine hands down this has ruined
my life
i got cut on this too this these should
not exist and i think this we need to
rail against these
all these are good for is picking up
that last little bit of soap
yeah right well you know what else
that's good for
drywall you can mud with that you can
mug with that
so yes i'll drywall myself a new pan
is there a quarantine purchase you made
that you regret or
absolutely love no i don't know i
i can't remember all the purchases i'm
i've been doing a lot of facebook
marketplace
uh mostly for companionship like i don't
need
uh oh you just want to get to know
someone via like i don't even want
an oscillating fan i did buy an
oscillating fan
i even bought a ceiling fan i didn't
need it i just was like
i need to meet somebody i need to see a
person
so like the driveway exchange is the
most
um it's the most uh human
connection i've had is is like
okay i i like i'm like okay i'll venmo
you
or i can bring cash but you don't have
to stand within six feet of me but could
you please just bring it outside and say
hello
and and and um it's i met so many nice
people
i 100 know what you mean it's very
embarrassing and i did not expect to
admit this
but i i just my desk works i had to get
one off of craigslist
it's like a new desk quick for this and
uh uh yeah
i was this woman she came outside and
gave me this desk and
we were talking for a little bit and i
had like like nerves like it was like a
first date right
it's scary to see real people and
facebook it
is so much different than craigslist
where it's like no i don't want any
contact here's cash i don't want to look
at you
facebook marketplace you have the whole
profile of someone right
and they're queuing on theories so you
really can hit it off quick
sure you can you can you can really
you can really hit it up quick or not um
i
bought ease and i learned a lot about q
great well um
i got a problem moses yeah i just added
to my workload
oh no see one's got to go
they can't both be in there i can't
shower this
much i can't now it's not down
now it's not two soaps it's three soaps
i gotta use up
i i'm not wonder woman
your life has has taken a real depth he
started on a high we're very proud of
this and then this broke
yeah i i um i'm just getting word that
okay yeah that conan is no longer
sending the new album cover he's very
upset
about the this so oh
yeah yeah he does want to invest in the
sleep hair business though
oh yeah sleep here that would be a great
brand ambassador
sleep here that's where it's at that's
the only reason i'm here pitching
we don't need a shark tank we don't need
that people already
know they need somebody to do their hair
while they're sleeping
like it's an ah that's a no-brainer yeah
if you want to get going on it with this
online internet money you're making
you can please invest in this business
it's actually called better hair
b-e-d-d-e oh
see this is great please invest please
invest please watch your stuff online
merry mack comedy comedy comedy
well this is great i know it's good
moses
we're business partners now we're
business partners forever this
i thought this is gonna be interview but
i walked away with a lifelong
cash machine money money money okay i'm
muting see you later
okay thank you very much